former acting FBI director Andrew McCabe
argues that the president is dishonest
in his new book the threat
now the FBI protects America in the age
of terror and Trump McCabe writes quote
the president exposes himself as a
deliberate liar someone who will say
whatever he pleases to get whatever he
wishes if he were on the box at Quantico
meaning at an FBI lie-detector he would
break the machine Andrew McCabe is here
in studio 57 good morning good morning
John before we get to the president I
want to ask you about the Muller report
sure so it might come out as or it might
be delivered as early as next week to
the Justice Department you write in your
book about handling the Hillary Clinton
email investigation and the internal
deliberations over how to report your
findings to the public that's right
reflecting on that experience how do you
think the Muller report should be
handled when it's handed over well it's
it's I think it's very easy to compare
the two and that the kind of headline
approach but obviously the circumstances
are fundamentally different I know that
many people had issues with the way that
we handled the July announcement of our
investigative results in the Hillary
Clinton case so that's something I'm
sure that the folks at the Justice
Department will be thinking about as
they decide what to do with this report
I can say that from my own perspective I
think it's imperative that the report is
shared in its most robust form first and
foremost with Congress and I think that
following that the American people have
a right to know as much information as
is possible it can come out from the
report the rod Rosen signed this week
made headlines when he said that
transparency doesn't always work best
when it comes to government revelations
do you support what he said and do you
think that he was alluding to the Mullah
report not being seen by the public or
even Congress well I think rod was
referring to the longtime DOJ policy or
practice of not sharing facts and
circumstances of cases that are not
charged and that certainly is the
precedent in the tradition but as we
know we also have a Justice Department
that has many examples of departing from
precedent tradition in the recent past I
think that the incredibly extensive
sharing of not just report conclusions
but FBI
underlying investigative materials in
the Hillary Clinton case sharing at an
unprecedented rate with the hill those
are decisions made by the Department of
Justice and I think they'll have a tough
time reconciling that act with the
Deputy Attorney General statements mr.
McCabe that the country watched Michael
Cohen testified to Congress
congressional oversight this week did
you find him a credible witness
well mr. Cohen clearly has some
significant credibility problems I mean
it's not often that you hear a witness
testified who's already pled guilty to
lying to Congress but it's I think
important to note Alex that prosecutors
and agents have a lot of experience
working with witnesses that have
credibility problems in the way that you
rehabilitate those witnesses is you let
them tell their story but then you back
that story up with corroborating
information corroborating evidence the
thing I found fascinating by Michael
Cohen statements was the amount of
exactly that sort of corroborating
information that he referred to and
maybe revealed in his testimony so there
is a lot - there's a lot there I
wouldn't dismiss mr. Cohen as a witness
who would be you know unhelpful to the
to any sort of prosecutorial efforts
simply by virtue of the his guilty plea
in his own case you write in the book
that the president is a threat to the
nation part of that is what you identify
his lack of candor what is that what do
you mean by that I think that the
president's relentless attacks on the
FBI and on the intelligence community
writ large or make the job of protecting
this country keeping our citizens safe
harder every day in many many ways
there's the obvious overt attacks on
things like recruiting cooperating
witnesses and ongoing prosecutions
techniques that are absolutely lawful
and in some ways form the bedrock of our
ability to be successful in big
complicated cases all the way down to
just the constant undermining of the
work that the men and women of the FBI
do every day referring to investigations
as baseless witch hunts and things like
that
it is dispiriting I think it arose their
ability to get in the game and do the
job every day and it erodes public
confidence in the work that they
which is not helpful let me ask you
about the news overnight that the
president reportedly intervened on
behalf of Jared Kushner to get him a
top-secret security clearance did you
know about this given the fact that the
FBI conducts background checks and how
unusual is it for a president to
intervene on behalf of somebody so my
knowledge of this situation is limited
to the reporting that I've seen today
but I will say in my own experience I
have been involved with high-level
security clearance matters for many
years I have never seen a president or
an administration react to the
recommendation of the professionals in
this way there's a question that the
president has the ability the power to
do exactly what is alleged in the
article but I think it's one more
example that people should take very
seriously the mere fact that the
president has the authority to act in
this way doesn't necessarily make it a
good idea there is a very detailed
thoughtful careful process in place to
ensure that security clearances are only
given to people under optimal
circumstances when that process results
in a negative recommendation that is
something that I have always seen
administration's adhere to recruitment
is down at the FBI over the past 10
years specifically over the past few
years for top special agents how much of
any of that do you tribute to the
president constantly attacking the FBI
you know I don't I can't I don't have
the facts and figures to support that
but I mean it's it's it's undeniable it
doesn't help and the fact is we need a
consistent supply of the best and
brightest young minds that this country
has to offer
across the vast spectrum of talent that
we have to draw from to ensure that this
incredibly important work gets done
effectively every day not just today but
into the future and that is very
troubling to me as we talk about
reliability and reliable narrators is
important to bring up that the Inspector
General report that justified your
firing from the FBI says you quote
lacked candor on four separately what
does that mean did you lie and should
the American public believe what you
have to say in terms of you
assessment of the landscape they should
they should I would love to sort through
that report with you I disagree with the
conclusions contained there and what I
can tell you alex is I never
deliberately misled anyone not in the
accounts that they relate in that report
and not in any others I'm very proud of
the 21 years I spent serving in the FBI
serving this nation I did so with an
absolutely unblemished record until the
point at which the president decided to
start attacking me publicly so I have
deep disagreements with that report I
would ask the American people to judge
me on the work that I've done over the
course of that career really quickly do
you think the president is going to
finish his term I think that the
overwhelming likelihood is that he will
Andrew McCabe thank you for your time
thank you thank you